what's going on guys this is Rob and I
just woke up a little bit ago so you
have to bear with me but Fifth Avenue
and Harbor Drive over at San Diego
comic-con July 21st at 12 p.m. myself
and Mariah will be there because we want
to meet you guys hopefully you guys can
make it those are guys who have tickets
will be right around that area for those
you guys you don't have tickets
it'll be an outdoor meeting outside the
entrance right so that if you don't have
tickets and you can't go then you could
still come hang out with us anyway but I
want to give you guys notice about a
week in advance so you guys have plenty
of time to make arrangements or do
whatever you need to do to be able to
get out there if you can but it's gonna
be on a Sunday so hopefully you guys
aren't really working we kind of figured
it was the best time because we're
leaving on the 22nd so it'll probably be
about an hour so not too long so about
12:00 p.m. to 1:00 p.m. and then Mariah
and I are gonna go spend the rest of the
day check it out San Diego so yeah
hopefully we see you there